all I needed was a love you gave
you guys taken the test yeah three years
ago we were positive
and lifted
I founded the sense to do to take the
risk out of love no more uncertainty no
more wondering if you've chosen the
right partner no more divorce we were
the first to build the machines to
conduct a test to make the bond of love
stronger
I really want to work here
there really like who just fries
she's my favorite
I know
so you'll be shadowing a mirror he's
already one of our most successful
instructors what's the one thing you
love most about Maria take your time I
love her hair
it's soft
it's nice onset it's nice
the truth is we're all achingly lonely
and we're endlessly searching for ways
to fill that void I asked you something
why do you work at The Institute if you
understand love a little better
I really want to learn how the exercises
help you connect why are we doing this I
thought it'd be fun it's just
I think it's normal to get into a bit of
a routine I think relationships should
be worked on every day oh sorry
that one person could be in love with
two people at the same time it's a
biological impossibility yeah
what I thought too
[Music]
I need to tell you something
only you
foreign